on July 25th 1976 a NASA scientist was
studying the images of a region of Mars
called cydonia when something caught his
eye he had to take a second to process
what he was seeing he grabbed a
magnifying glass there was no doubt on
the surface of Mars 140 million miles
from Earth was a structure in the shape
of a human face it was huge about a mile
wide and showed two eyes a nose and a
mouth around the face were pyramids and
structures that didn't look natural they
looked like they were built by someone
the following day NASA held a press
conference of the thousands of photos
sent back from Mars all anyone asked
about was the face who built it and why
is it a message from an advanced
Civilization now long extinct is it a
religious artifact is it solid like the
Great Sphinx or could it contain
Chambers like the Great Pyramid then
NASA threw cold water on the speculation
they said there was a second photograph
of the area taken shortly after and that
photo showed that the face was nothing
more than an optical illusion small
problem that second photo doesn't exist
so why did NASA lie well the answer to
that question is in the other pictures
foreign
for centuries we've been captivated by
The Mysteries of the red planet the
ancient Egyptians saw Mars as a God the
Greeks named it after their God of War
but it wasn't until the 19th century
that we began to unravel some of its
secrets in 1877 Italian astronomer
Giovanni scaparelli made detailed
observations of Mars he saw strange
markings on the surface that he called
Canali oh I love those it's like an
Italian sweet cheese taco that's cannoli
delicious Canali means channels in
Italian but the media thought it meant
canals and this led to speculation that
the canals might have been built by an
intelligent race of martians and as
technology improved and with the space
race in full swing getting close-up
photos of Mars became a priority in 1965
the Mariner 4 probe flew past Mars and
sent back 22 images even though the
first pictures of Mars were exciting
they were also disappointing
there were no vast cities where canals
or any evidence of an ancient culture
Mars looked like the moon harsh Baron
pockmarked by meteors completely
lifeless but as technology continued to
improve the idea of Life on Mars became
less far-fetched yes Mars is cold and
Barren now but years ago that wasn't the
case
Mars was once covered with vast oceans
of water flowing into rivers and lakes
all over the planet it had a thick
atmosphere that kept the surface warm
Mars had volcanic activity and even a
global magnetic field just like Earth it
was a long time ago but the red planet
was at one time a blue planet with all
the ingredients necessary to support
life in 1975 NASA sent two spacecraft to
Mars Viking 1 and Viking 2. these probes
each contained an Orbiter with a high
resolution camera and a Lander in the
summer of 1976 biking 1 and Viking 2
finally reached Mars both orbiters took
thousands of photographs of the Martian
surface NASA scientist Toby Owen was one
of the first researchers assigned to
look for landing sites and when Owen
found the face on image
35-a72 he was beyond excited NASA
released the image to the press as a way
to increase public interest and attract
attention to Mars this worked but a
little too well because the face was the
only thing the Press wanted to talk
about it became such a big story that
NASA had to release a follow-up
statement about the face saying it was
just an optical illusion and they took
another photo to prove it isn't it
peculiar what tricks of light and Shadow
can do when we took another picture a
few hours later it all went away it was
just a trick just the way the light fell
on it
except that second photo was never
produced and nobody thought to ask face
or not cydonia was the top Contender for
the landing site of Viking 2. the
terrain is flat visibility was good and
there are interesting rock formations to
explore but a few days after the release
of the face photo Viking 2 landed in a
Barren Rocky region called Utopia
planitia one scientists working on the
mission complained that this was like
Landing in the Sahara Desert and
expecting to find a garden so why the
last minute change of the landing site
is there something going on in cydonia
that NASA doesn't want us to see well
the answer is yes lots of things
[Music]
monuments are not built in isolation the
pyramids found in Egypt or in Central or
South America were not single structures
they were part of sprawling complexes of
buildings Town squares and temples if an
ancient culture living on Mars created a
monument of a humanoid head we'd expect
to see other structures close by and
that's exactly what we see
there's a cluster of pyramids near the
face that people call the city square
and near those is an object nicknamed
The Fortress which appears to be a
collapsed pyramid there's a formation
called the DNM pyramid named for NASA
Imaging scientists Vince D Pietro and
Greg molinar DNM is a massive five-sided
one and a half mile tall structure this
is three times the size of the largest
Pyramid in Egypt but what's really
interesting about the DNM pyramid is
that it's symmetrical around two
different axes now it's easy to dismiss
these findings that it's nothing more
than a coincidence that all these weird
looking structures and pyramids are
within a few miles of the face but then
a professional satellite imaging
specialist named Errol tauren started
looking into it he worked for the
defense mapping agency and his job was
literally to analyze satellite images
and decide which objects were natural
and which were artificial he said that
all the objects including the face were
not of natural origin but the DNM
pyramid really blew his mind the
geomorphic natural hypothesis is thus
left with no mechanism that can explain
the formation of the DNM pyramid this
object's five-sided shape and bilateral
symmetry is unlike any landform seen to
date in this solar system tauren called
this pyramid the Rosetta Stone of Mars
he found all kinds of mathematical
relationships between objects in the
area and as more photos came back from
Mars we found more strange objects a lot
more
over the past 50 years thousands of
images have come back from Mars and if
you look through those images you'll
find all sorts of things that look out
of place this is an extremely tall
almost perfectly rectangular monolith
here's another monolith this one stands
over 10 miles high If This Were on Earth
it would extend up through the clouds
the top is so high that even the largest
airliners would fly below it
this object has been nicknamed the
Shipwreck because it looks like the
remains of a boat is it an ancient craft
or maybe the foundation of a structure
in May 2022 Curiosity Rover found a
doorway carved in the rock face
I wonder where it goes here are giant
tracks on the surface giant what kind of
machine could make this
now this object doesn't look like a
natural rock formation
this one is called The Martian totem
pole you can make the argument that
erosion created most of the odd features
on Mars but this one is very strange I
don't see how erosion could do this
curiosity took this picture in 2015. it
looks like something is hanging onto the
cliffs here's a dome or the top of a
sphere
these structures were famously called
glass worms by Arthur C Clarke
here's an object that's definitely not a
rock formation a series of still images
shows an orb of light moving around the
Martian landscape Skeptics say this is a
dead pixel but dead pixels don't move
around the frame besides whatever this
is It's larger than just a pixel here's
one that blows my mind this looks like
the imprint of a valve or a gear this
was taken with the opportunities
microscopic imager could this be the
imprint left by the piece of an ancient
machine how could this Mark be formed
naturally how about this this was taken
by the Mars Global surveyor in the year
2000. this saucer-shaped formation or
structure really stands out from the
surrounding landscape and these are just
a few of the anomalies found on Mars
there are many many more a few years
after the release of the infamous face
photo Dipietro and molinar decided to
look for the original so they could
analyze it themselves at first they had
trouble locating it turns out it was
misfiled eventually they found 35 a72
labeled head in the Viking image files
and after reviewing the photo Dipietro
molinar felt that despite what NASA
claimed there was more to the face than
a trick of light and Shadow so they
looked for the second image the one that
NASA said proves the face is Just an
Illusion how did they find it Well it
was misfiled but they did find a second
photo of the face and this one has even
more detail
foreign
ER felt that there was more to the face
on Mars than an optical illusion to
prove or disprove the theory they would
need more photos even though there were
other pictures taken of the face they
were surprised to find that they seemed
to have disappeared oh they was
surprised that NASA lost the pictures at
they must be new at this uh tell me
again what happened to NASA's recordings
of the moon landing oh yeah they lost
those two unless
does seem to be the case you know it's a
good thing the moon landing was fake
otherwise that would have been really
embarrassing they also couldn't find the
quote-unquote disconfirming photographs
that Gerald soffit mentioned five years
earlier but even though it was filed in
the wrong place they did find a second
photo of the face on Mars and this
second image showed more detail and less
shadow on the left side of the face
there appeared to be two eye sockets a
nose and even a mouth but the weirdest
thing was that the structure had two
parallel and even length sides both
hundreds of yards long and perfectly
straight and the top and bottom edges
were both curved and had the same radius
it looked like a symmetrical framed
platform for the face itself according
to geologists and imaging experts the
faces base if that's what it is is
different than anything you'd likely see
in nature Dipietro did more analysis and
found evidence of a pupil in the left
eye socket NASA scoffed at the new
findings so the two researchers sought
some outside help and this is where
science journalist Richard ho stepped
into the picture he organized an
independent research group and began
studying the images in Greater detail
computer Imaging specialist Dr Mark
carlato was brought onto the team his
new image enhancement techniques showed
what looked like teeth in the mouth and
an odd stripe pattern on the frame areas
excited by what they found Hoagland
arranged for a briefing on the results
with Carl Sagan at Nasa Carl Sagan the
millions of billions got I went to
turtleneck sweaters yep that's him have
trillions Millions billion trillions
billions
trillion Millions million millions
millions
billions Millions
million million Millions at the meeting
Carl Sagan acted impressed but he
attacked the face on Mars theory in the
newspapers Oakland pressed NASA for more
photos but NASA said it was unnecessary
mystery solved but NASA didn't realize
that Richard Hoagland had a platform a
big platform
oh
and the high desert has a great American
southwest have you all good evening good
morning good afternoon wherever you may
be in whatever time zone wherever you
are in the world this is Coast to Coast
AM and I'm Art Bell break me here lots
to do tonight our Bell host of Coast to
Coast AM reached millions of people and
Richard Hoagland was on the show all the
time with access to Art Bell's audience
Hoagland was able to generate letter
writing and call-in campaigns to force
NASA to take new pictures of the face
and pyramids at cydonia now NASA didn't
agree immediately but the pressure was
starting to mount because in just a few
more months NASA was going back to Mars
foreign
1993 NASA launched the Mars Observer the
first mission to Mars since the Viking
days and liftoff liftoff of the Titan
free rocket with the Mars Observer and
America's return to the red planet
and NASA wasn't even going to include a
camera but an uproar from the public
forced NASA to include one there was a
lot of excitement about the Mars
Observer because the new camera was good
enough to finally end the debate about
the face and the pyramids in cydonia at
least that was the hope the reality was
somewhat different even after the launch
NASA maintained that they had no
interest in photographing the face or
cydonia the debate went back and forth
until about three days before Mars
Observer was inserted into Mars orbit
the probe insertion don't don't be an
infant that Sunday morning before the
maneuver did the maneuver to insert the
probe stop it the Sunday before the
Observer was placed into orbit NASA sent
out the Mars Observer lead project
scientist Dr Bevin French to debate
Hoagland on Good Morning America now to
put it gently it did not go well for Dr
French or NASA we now have set of data
so extraordinary that it demands in the
venue of any decent science simply
testing the hypothesis
the problem is that there are some folks
in NASA in charge of the next mission
going back specifically that camera I
referred to who seem less than
overwhelmingly inclined to perform the
simple test
they will not guarantee strange as it
may seem
they're taking new pictures is on the
Mars Observer agenda by the end of the
debate even the host was asking NASA why
don't you just take the pictures and
prove these guys wrong Dr French didn't
have a good answer for that but what
happened next was even more suspicious
less than five minutes after the debate
aired NASA made an announcement the Mars
Observer probe had disappeared they'd
lost all contact with it wait what so it
didn't matter who won the debate there
would be no pictures of Mars they lost
this thing too yep uh you know NASA
might want to invest in some air tags or
something to help him keep track of all
this stuff good idea you know at the end
of the day at Nasa I picked your 400
scientists just just wandering around a
puck and let that you know looking for
where they looked at cuz and here's an
interesting side note Hoagland and
others claimed they were getting leaked
information from NASA insiders according
to the leakers the Mars Observer was
still out there and running just fine in
fact it was taking pictures of the face
and all kinds of other weird objects on
Mars but even if NASA had those pictures
they couldn't show them publicly
especially if they showed the face was
an artificial construction NASA
continued to claim that the face was
nothing more than a pile of rocks but
since they couldn't take a photo to
prove it they did the next best thing
they created one
[Music]
five years after the Mars Observer
Fiasco NASA launched a new probe called
Mars Global surveyor three two one we
have ignition
and we have liftoff uh says Mars Global
surveyor as America begins its Journey
Back to the red planet and even though
there were newer better cameras
available NASA insisted on using the old
ones and once again NASA didn't want to
take pictures of cydonia or the face but
after public pressure they finally
agreed to take a few pictures then NASA
finally made a big announcement on April
5th 1998 NASA finally released a highly
detailed picture of the face on Mars
what the hell
what was released was a grainy
noise-filled image of the face in bad
lighting bad weather and with multiple
filters applied that night on the Art
Bell program Oakland and his team were
upset Bell said that from his
perspective the image looked like
something my kitty would scratch up in
her cat box and from that moment forward
it would be forever known as the cat box
image but it looked like this image was
deliberately manipulated by NASA land
Fleming a NASA contractor went back to
the source data and tried to reproduce
the cat box image at first he couldn't
but eventually after applying 14
different Photoshop filters he was able
to do it and he realized this could not
be done by accident
JPL removed most of the tonal variation
in the original image that gives the
Observer the visual cues to the real
three-dimensional shape of the object
they added false visual cues to give the
object its rough jumbled appearance
inadvertently falsifying the appearance
of the surrounding terrain as well the
tapbox is not a poor enhancement as it
is often called it is a crude but very
effective fraud perpetrated by employees
or contractors to the United States
government even if the face is proven to
be completely natural this is
inexcusable misconduct and a gross abuse
of power if the face ultimately is
proven to be artificial the cat box will
certainly come to be regarded as the
greatest most malicious and most
destructive scientific hoax of all time
ever since the first color images came
back from Mars they've always been
suspicious
the colors were dominated by this weird
orange Haze NASA said this is because of
all the carbon dioxide and red dust in
the atmosphere well a carbon dioxide
atmosphere would still be blue not a
deep blue like on Earth but a grayish
blue but the images from Mars show the
sky is this weird reddish green color so
what's going on
these photos make the surface of Mars
look like a weird alien world but it's
not an accurate representation of color
nothing is so uniformly one color like
this for some reason before releasing
images of Mars they ran the images
through an orange filter now in the
1990s nobody would really question this
but modern digital photography software
like Photoshop can tell if a single
color is applied to an image uniformly
this is a simple calculation for
software it's how white balancing is
achieved in photography and video it's
such an easy calculation that current
versions of Photoshop give you a
one-click way to solve for false color
the function is called well Auto color
so look at this early very blurry image
of Mars that looks like Mars well the
version of Mars that's been fed to us
for years but remember Photoshop can
correct for false color if we Auto color
this whoa right now that's a very
different image let's do a few more
[Music]
whoa
NASA eventually learned that their
orange filter technique was easily
spotted so recent pictures of Mars no
longer have the weird orange tint now
even NASA's pictures show a blue gray
sky and a lot of different colors in the
landscape but why would NASA not want us
to know that Mars has blue skies some
say it's to discourage people from
wanting to visit Mars the more alien it
looks the better so Mars had oceans and
a thick atmosphere and could have
supported life if intelligent life did
evolve on Mars and the face and other
artifacts are not piles of rocks but are
actually ruins of a long-lost society we
have to ask what happened to that
ancient civilization well the answer to
that question could be the reason that
the governments of the world have lied
to us about Mars for so many years
because there is evidence scientific
evidence that millions of years ago the
planet Mars was devastated by a massive
Global nuclear war
foreign
Rover arrived on Mars in August 2012 and
started analyzing samples from the
surface NASA scientists were expecting
to find soil containing heavily oxidized
iron which they did but what nobody
expected to find was evidence of a
massive nuclear war chemical analysis
revealed that the top layer of Martian
soil contains a large amount of
xenon-129 there's only one known process
that creates this particular isotope of
xenon the detonation of nuclear weapons
now over the course of 70 years over 1
000 nuclear tests have been conducted on
Earth and every time a nuclear bomb is
detonated the explosion leaves behind
small traces of xenon-129 the amount of
xenon 129 in Martian soil is two and a
half times higher than Earth Dr John
Brandenburg is a former NASA physicist
and a well-known Mars researcher he was
a scientist who accompanied Richard
Hoagland to NASA to present their
findings about the face in cydonia Dr
Brandenburg believes that a humanoid
civilization lived on Mars and died on
Mars I have shown this to several
nuclear weapons experts and they have
affirmed that this is nuclear weapon
signature there is no other process that
can create such a Xenon spectral
for so much Xenon to be deposited on the
surface the nuclear weapon would have to
be the size of the Empire State Building
with an energy equivalent to 1 000
megatons for comparison the bomb dropped
on Hiroshima was 20 kilotons so we're
talking an explosion 50 000 times more
powerful and Dr Brandenburg found two
hot spots on Mars where radiation levels
are higher than anywhere else and right
in between those hot spots is cydonia
the location of the face the pyramid and
the other structures dating the Isotopes
places the explosions somewhere between
150 and 300 million years ago Mars was
at one time a blue planet like Earth
covered in oceans and a thick atmosphere
but nobody knows for sure how Mars lost
its atmosphere a nuclear explosion of
this size would answer that question now
this is a frightening Theory but it gets
even more disturbing if an intelligent
race created the face and other
structures on Mars they wouldn't have
been that technologically advanced they
were maybe an Iron Age civilization
those people would not have the
technology to create such a devastating
nuclear weapon this means the weapons
were detonated by someone else don't say
aliens don't say aliens aliens
time of this event on Mars the most
advanced creatures on Earth were
reptiles dinosaurs hadn't even evolved
yet maybe whoever destroyed Mars ignored
us reptiles wouldn't pose much of a
threat to them but what if they return
another theory is that intelligent life
on Mars did reach an advanced level of
technology advanced enough to destroy
themselves in a nuclear apocalypse but
before that catastrophic event a small
group of these humanoids escaped off
world so who were those martians that
managed to escape Annihilation well
they're us
[Music]
foreign
for a show like this the exploration of
Mars is a gift that started giving in
the 1960s and just keeps on giving we've
got ancient civilizations government
cover-ups alien invasions a nuclear
apocalypse and more conspiracies than I
can count but how much of all this is
true well I can't really debunk most of
this episode because well Mars is
another planet it's not like we can go
see for ourselves at least not yet the
flow of information comes from a single
Source the United States government well
assume everything they say is a lie
that's a pessimistic point of view and
what can I tell you I've been hurt
before but let me give you some
perspective first every single object on
Mars that looks artificial could be
attributed to paradolia that's a word
you'll hear a lot from NASA paradolia is
the human tendency to find meaning in
random stimuli like the imperfections of
a piece of wood that look like a polar
bear or a stadium that looks like a UFO
or a cloud shaped like a crab kid right
kid seeing animals is common but the
most common thing we see
in fact if you look at the Wiki page for
paradolia the picture of the face on
Mars is the main example
what do you mean Wikipedia isn't biased
you're adorable but is the face on Mars
an optical illusion or is there
something there well plenty of
scientists NASA scientists thought there
was something there though we don't hear
much from them anymore most scientists
think it's just an illusion when NASA
released their detailed picture of the
face which showed it has a pile of rocks
they thought they put the conspiracy to
bed the problem is NASA does alter
images in fact they alter every image
they release to the public and now Chris
Martinez is introducing us to two of the
artists behind some of the most iconic
space art in the Galaxy NASA says this
is to make the images easier to
understand or to make them more visually
appealing yeah even Nasa uses filters on
her instant they do now I don't like
that NASA has artists on staff to
photoshop images but I understand that
some photos have to be adjusted to make
them more digestible to the public but
there are some really weird NASA
photoshops here's the famous photo of
the earth taken from Apollo 17. and
here's a 3D model of the Earth released
by Google and the US Navy the model is
supposed to be mathematically perfect
but the land masses don't line up like
not even close here are examples of NASA
copy pasting clouds on a picture of the
Earth
the copy paste technique has been used
on Mars images too these are from the
Curiosity Rover
now maybe there are good reasons for
faking these images though I can't think
of any but if you fake one image we
can't trust any of them so when you see
this picture of Mars
people say this looks exactly like Devon
Island the uninhabited Island in Canada
where NASA trains crew members and
testus Rovers
I wanted to talk to you
talk to you about it from Curiosity this
looks like Devon Island but with an
orange filter on no no that's Mars yeah
but it's the red planet yeah no I know
it's called the red planet but I'm
pretty sure this picture of Devon Island
got uh slipped in accidentally no no
no one that's sparse okay then why is
this animal hiding behind the rocks
okay but that sure does look like an
Arctic lemming what the hell
dick lemming is a type of small rodent
that hides in the Rocks all over Devon
Island
hello all right you know what thank you
and your stupid YouTube channel you
could take your Arctic learning and
shove it straight up your ass
so how much you trust NASA is up to you
but I wouldn't trust them 100 but some
people go to the extreme with the Mars
images now below this Eagle is a whole
city of bird and deer formations in the
Sedona area there's a parrot look again
there's the parrot again now if you're
uh looking at this area directly below
the crater that has the uh the eagle in
it they see parrots and dolphins and all
sorts of things in the pictures
now I don't see these things unless
they're specifically pointed out to me I
think most of those images are a stretch
but I don't need anyone to hold my hand
with the picture of the face that one I
can clearly see as for Richard Hoagland
you've heard me talk about him a lot
especially on the after files live
stream he was always one of my favorite
guests on Art Bell very well spoken guy
very entertaining but he has plenty of
detractors he's been a favorite Target
of sites like bad astronomy and
skeptical Inquirer he's been accused of
exaggerating his credentials and his
experience but let me come to Richard's
defense a little bit all scientists do
that Richard Hoagland might be wrong
about some things and I think he's
probably wrong about most things but
he's provided a valuable service and
it's something I don't think he gets
enough credit for he got millions of
regular folks interested in the space
program and because of that he was able
to sway NASA into taking pictures of
Mars that we might not have ever seen
and he's shown us that we have to keep
an eye on NASA we need people like
Richard Hoagland out there we need
watchdogs specifically Watchdogs with
access and with the ability to influence
policy as for Dr John Brandenburg and
his nuclear war on Mars Theory Dr
Brandenburg is well respected and well
credentialed his earliest papers on the
Mars theory was that a nuclear event
happened naturally on the planet there's
a uranium mine in Gabon Africa which
shows evidence of nuclear fission
occurring naturally so it's not a
stretch to think this could happen on
Mars but after a while Dr Brandenburg
claimed that what happened on Mars did
not happen naturally that the only way
we see isotopes of xenon-129 is from the
discharge of a nuclear weapon now I've
read both sides of this argument and I'm
not sure who's right but Dr Brandon
burries Mars nuclear war theory was
rejected for peer review but that's
mainstream scientists though they're not
always correct but they always have an
agenda right or wrong it's an
interesting theory that deserves
attention and study not ridicule but you
can't talk about Mars without being
ridiculed yes most everything we see in
photographs from Mars can be explained
but there are couple of things that
can't we've sent mission after mission
to Mars and I can't for the life of me
understand why we haven't sent a Rover
through cydonia and right up to the
object that's supposed to be a face NASA
says there's nothing there so it would
be a waste of resources but with all due
respect to NASA their resources come
from we the people and we the people
want to know what the face on Mars
really is now until we have close-up
photographs of cydonia close-up
photographs that we can trust are
undoctored the story about the face on
Mars is not going away and not as long
as it generates clicks huh true and look
I completely agree that the chances of
the face being an artificial structure
are almost zero but almost zero isn't
zero if there's even the slightest
chance that the face and the pyramids
were created by a civilization on Mars
we deserve to know but more importantly
the people who built those monuments
they deserve to be remembered
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ you know Heckle
fish this has been the Y piles if you
had fun or learned anything do us a
favor like comment subscribe share that
stuff really helps the channel and like
most topics we cover here today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the yfiles.com tips and special
thanks to our patrons who make this
channel possible you guys are the engine
that keeps this thing going and if you'd
like to support the channel consider
becoming a member on patreon or grab
something from the Wi-Fi store
t-shirts are available are they really
limited edition hey I'm just Talent they
give me a script I read it I cash my
check fair enough that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
foreign